doing stan he did he was doing the music
thing at the uh the the outro show he
was a part of the dude he did like five
to seven different things the whole yeah
it was crazy yeah we did like a meet and
greet after the show though
steve do you know my favorite part is
because we've never been on that was
like our first like festival show on the
road is steve did the meet and greet
before the show
so there was a line outside and he
walked up to everybody in the line he
goes thank you so much for coming
[Music]
for half an hour i can't find him
anywhere and then he comes he comes and
he's sitting on the front of the stage
grossest thing i've ever seen he's
sitting on the front of the stage while
people are coming in i go steve where
you been he goes i just do the meet and
greet i go
we do that after he goes
yeah i want to thank people for coming i
know i go all right well there's no
wrong answer so there you go do you do
you it was great that's great man no no
build your self-esteem
okay this dude is out there like
this is what he did
he shows up right he's like i'm so sorry
i'm gonna get my fishing rod
and i'm going to go fish for compliments
i don't think yeah yes so he's out there
right thankful george edit this out
i swear to god dude
holy [ __ ]
i
yeah don't get angry don't times no no
it's fine it's fine i'm trying to learn
you guys are on stage ever you know i
understand
i appreciate it all right i appreciate
it that's all but can we just do this
though from now on yeah
wait afterwards and also
create some mystery right because it's
like that's what i told them backstage i
was abusing i was hitting myself in the
morning i'm like oh i missed you yeah
yeah it's like you got excited it's all
good but so basically you went through
the line
and said to individual people every
single one let me just imagine every
single thanks for coming to the show and
supporting us
i bet you said this do you like it
did you know what you said do you like
it what do you mean like the podcast
[ __ ] around you listen right
yeah it's good don't [ __ ] around anyway
thanks for coming
thanks for coming again right but
the next question is to where to go
real quick yeah [ __ ] strike you dude
what do you like about it
yeah yeah right he probably says stuff
like this too yeah we're improving and
we're gonna get better
right
just amateur [ __ ] right
yeah wait afterwards
okay you know what we're going to do
yeah yeah
we talked about this on the drive over
can i can i mention this steve yeah go
ahead the last time he was on stage was
at the tempe improv
and i'm headlining a weekend there next
month yeah and he asked me to do a guest
spot
i have to you have to right right
you have to full circle closure i have
to do do you think they have the same
management i don't i have to do it for
me
because it's like state you know i
choked that's it's like i have another
oh i get to go to the tournament again
i have to oh also